my company just moved a couple weeks ago
from one office building to another
we had been across the street from
Google headquarters and now we're a few
miles down the road at near the Great
America theme park
so at the moment my office is pristine
but that's because I haven't actually
worked in it yet my office would be tend
to be rather messier I the way I think
is is not linear the way I consider
problems I just have to let things
stewar round bubble like a I can't say
what's going to be important but pretty
soon the important thing bubbles up to
my consciousness and then I do something
about it so my office tends to reflect
that you know I got my hands in 30 or 40
different pots simultaneously and and so
I have a little bit of all of that where
I work
oh I'm definitely a night owl I I get
going about the time my wife crashes and
goes to bed and in some sense I've had
to learn to be more more of a cat Napper
in recent years because Perl development
Perl designer development has become a
worldwide phenomenon and not just
mailing list but IRC channels Twitter
even this all happens 24 hours a day and
people come up with questions at any
time of day or night I have people
working on this in Europe and Japan
China Australia India South America all
over the world except maybe Antarctica
oh I think we even have Perl programmer
in Antarctica but so I've had to learn
to kind of sense when the when the
questions would be coming and be ready
to handle them there's a lot of
Education and reiteration that happens
on these online channels and it's
sometimes it's tempting to just say
tempting to could just say well just go
and read the documentation but you know
people appreciate being led along and
taught and mentored and this is part of
the reason I'm not too concerned about
the feature of Perl after me because I
see how these people are interacting
with each other and even when I'm not
there they are there helping each other
and solving each other's problems in a
way that even in way that I could not do
even if I were there so while I have
historically been a light light worker
you know sometimes I even like to get up
early and and see what's happened in the
few hours of the night and then I often
take a nap in the middle of the day just
to sort of make up for stretching my day
out
well mmm coffee is my drug of choice
generally with a little bit of Pepsi
here and there if I need more sugar but
yeah if I could do intravenous coffee I
would but I guess that's pretty standard
I used to not be able to listen to music
I was raised a musician and I played in
classical music violin in orchestras and
music comedy theaters I have music
running around in my head all the time
and if I hear music that's too
interesting I have to pay attention to
it for a while there I I could really
only work if I had sounds of ocean surf
in my head lightly though I find that a
music like that is very complicated
structurally like jazz I can actually
listen to that and work at the same time
because I could just let it wash over me
and not have to bother analyzing it it
just that works for me
never never put off till tomorrow what
you can put off till the day after
tomorrow I like a variant of the song
tomorrow only it's more the idea the
Mexican idea of manana mañana mañana I
love you manana you're always a day away
so yeah I procrastinate but mostly
because there's always too many things
to do and I got to stew in my mind that
things do bubble up yeah so I'll throw
things in there and let them stew around
and it's sort of like greasing the
squeaky wheels in my own brain when
something gets loud enough or I feel
guilty enough about it or somebody else
complains about it or I just feel it's
it's the next thing to do then then the
thing will de procrastinate itself at an
appropriate time and basically uh you
know there's just so much stuff flowing
past on the internet now you have you
have to let most of it go and I've grown
accustomed to the process of not
worrying too much about the stuff I'm
not getting to because the important
stuff will come back around